Через дев'ять місяців після повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну
німецькі політики не мають особливих ілюзій
щодо можливості швидких мирних переговорів.
Навіть Столітня війна між Англією та Францією колись закінчилася.
І сьогодні ці країни живуть у мирі та дружбі.
І Тридцятирічна війна закінчилася.
І українсько-російська війна, російське вторгнення в Україну колись закінчиться миром.
Просто зараз з погляду дипломатії навряд чи можна досягти
мирного рішення, такого, як ми всі бажаємо.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський, виступаючи на саміті Великої двадцятки на Балі,
представив пропозиції України щодо досягнення миру з Росією.
У плані, який отримав назву "Формула миру", - 10 пунктів.
Вони включають: гарантію ядерної, продовольчої та енергетичної безпеки України,
звільнення всіх полонених та депортованих українців,
відновлення територіальної цілісності країни, виведення російських військ
та припинення бойових дій, відновлення справедливості, протидія екоциду,
недопущення ескалації, фіксація закінчення війни.
Зеленський заявив, що війна має бути закінчена
"на основі статуту ООН та міжнародного права".
Не варто пропонувати Україні компроміси із совістю,
суверенітетом, територією та незалежністю.
І якщо Росія каже, що нібито хоче закінчити цю війну,
хай доведе це діями. Очевидно, що словам Росії довіряти неможливо,
і не буде жодних "Мінськів-3", які Росія порушить одразу ж після укладення.
Якщо ж відповідних дій для відновлення миру не буде,
то це означає, що Росія просто хоче вкотре обманути всіх вас,
обманути світ і заморозити війну якраз тоді,
коли її поразки стали особливо відчутними.
Водночас Зеленський заявив, що всі переговори мають відбуватися публічно.
З цим не зовсім погоджуються деякі німецькі експерти.
Таємна дипломатія останнім часом зазнавала жорсткої критики.
Однак мені здається, що нам якнайшвидше потрібна саме таємна дипломатія.
У громадській думці все тоне у пропагандистських наративах
усіх залучених сторін, а подібні речі не можна обговорювати відкрито.
Нині нам потрібна таємна дипломатія.
Всі ті, хто ще в змозі вести один з одним розумну розмову,
повинні використовувати шанси таємної дипломатії,
тобто переговори за лаштунками, в ході яких можна спробувати
конфіденційно промацати, що взагалі реально.
Усі ці шанси треба використати.
І щойно випаде шанс, зробити наступний крок
і створити ситуацію, в якій у виграші виявляться всі сторони.
І насамперед - Україна.
Німецькі політики розраховують, що під тиском економічних проблем,
викликаних унікальними за масштабом санкціями,
Росія все ж таки буде готова на хоч якісь переговори.
Чинні зараз санкції вкрай шкідливі для Росії та її економіки.
Ми також бачили, що після оголошення мобілізації додаткових
300 тисяч людей дуже багато молодих людей покинули Росію.
А ще до цього поїхало дуже багато фахівців у сфері IT.
Тобто Росія зазнала тяжких втрат у результаті цієї війни,
проте все це не призвело до того,
щоб у головах російського керівництва хоч щось змінилося.
На думку експертів, єдиним реальним міжнародним посередником
у можливих переговорах може бути Туреччина,
а не Німеччина чи Європейський Союз.
На даний момент ситуація така, що Туреччина та президент Ердоган
- єдині, хто може виконувати роль посередника.
Китайці від цього відмовилися. Незважаючи на обережне дистанціювання від Путіна,
вони не використали свого великого шансу стати міжнародним миротворцем.
А якщо тепер поставити запитання, чи може Захід чи європейські інститути
взяти на себе цю роль, то це, звичайно, непросто.
Зважаючи на їхню дуже чітку і однозначну позицію на стороні України,
вони навряд чи підходять на цю роль.
Більше половини бюджету МЗС Німеччини 2023 року,
який саме перебуває на обговоренні, припадає на статтю "Забезпечення миру та стабільності"
і, зокрема, на фінансування міжнародних організацій,
наприклад, Міжнародного комітету "Червоний хрест" або МАГАТЕ.
Робота міжнародних організацій особливо важлива під час війни,
кажуть у німецькому МЗС, оскільки в тому числі
й їхніми каналами здійснюється та сама дипломатія за зачиненими дверима,
яка в ідеалі має призвести до припинення вогню.